The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK.
All right.
Good morning.
So we're doing finite elements.
The element that we
considered so far
was the basic linear element.
Continuous, but of course,
the slopes have jumps.
The slope was minus one
over delta x for that one.
This one was a plus
and then a minus.
So a jump in slope but
no jump in the function.
So actually, my
abbreviation for that
would be C zero, saying
that it's continuous
but no derivative is continuous.
And now we'll get
to some elements
where the slope is continuous.
It's sort of fun to create
these finite elements of higher
degree.
It's pretty
straightforward in 1-D.
And that's where we are now.
So we'll get second degree
elements and third degree
elements.
And that gives us, as
we'll see, higher accuracy.
So I want to connect the
degree of the polynomials
to the accuracy of
the approximation.
Part of that connection
is to recognize
that these problems have
a strong form, as we know,
the equation; a
weak form, that's
the one that has test functions;
and also a minimum form
that we'll see.
So how would I get some
quadratics, so second degree
elements, parabolas,
into the picture?
You remember Galerkin's idea?
Choose trial functions.
And we're taking those to be
the same as the test function.
So these are the trial
functions we've chosen.
One, two, three, four of them.
And they're linear.
And that limits the
accuracy that you can get,
because your approximations
then are combinations of those.
So they're like
broken-line functions,
linear approximations.
And the accuracy is not great.
It's sort of the
lowest level possible.
So how would you get parabolas?
So this was first guy.
The second guy is going to
be continuous and quadratic.
So it's going to have
new trial functions.
In addition to these, I'm
going to put in some more.
Galerkin's happy with that.
I still proceed as usual.
My approximation is some
combination of those.
It's only going
to be continuous.
So it'll just be a
C zero guy again.
That means jump in slope.
The first derivative
isn't there.
Eventually, I want
to get to a C one
where the slopes are continuous.
OK, but how would I
get some quadratics?
All I want now is my functions,
my space, my combinations,
should be the
piecewise parabolas
instead of piecewise linear.
And the pieces are
broken at the nodes.
OK, so here is a way to do it.
Inside each interval,
I'm going to add,
I'll just call them
bubble functions.
So these will be
new additional guys.
So this will be my first phi.
You remember that half hat?
Because the problem I was
doing was a free fixed problem.
That's why I had a
half hat at this end,
because there was no boundary
condition that my functions had
to satisfy.
At this end, there was.
It was fixed.
So that's why the hat ended,
and there was no half hat,
there's no extra function there.
So I have right now
one, two, three, four.
I'm going to add four
more bubble functions.
Each one will be
inside an interval.
So it'll be a little parabola.
This is function
number whatever.
If I number this number one,
let's say, phi_1, now --
that's probably a
change in numbering --
phi_2 is going to be my bubble.
And you see what my
bubble function is?
It's a function that
goes there and straight.
So it is continuous, no jumps,
and it is second degree.
It's a parabola, and
I'll make its height one.
And then there'll
be another function.
If I had another
color I could draw it.
Well, I'll just do it
with broken lines, maybe.
So there'll be another
bubble function in here,
a third bubble function
in the third interval,
and a fourth in the
fourth interval.
You see that I've now got
my old phi_1, phi_3, phi_5,
and phi_7 were
the hat functions.
But now I've got a phi_2,
phi_4, phi_6, and phi_8 that
are these new trial functions.
So part of the
message is, we can
throw in additional functions.
They don't have
to be polynomials,
but those are the
simplest choices.
Why are they simple?
Because, you remember, that in
the end when I made the choice,
I have to do various
integrations.
So you remember that I have to
integrate to find entries K_ij.
Do you remember what that
integral looked like?
You certainly remember F_i.
That was the integral from zero
to one of whatever function
phi_i we had, times the
f(x)dx, times the load.
And we computed these.
You remember we computed these
for the piecewise linear guys.
But I don't think I wrote
down the expression that we
were really doing, so
let me just do that.
It's c(x), there's a du--
No. d phi_j/dx and a dV_i/dx.
Those were the integrals
that we had to do.
And we were taking phis
to be the same as V's.
Maybe I'll just do that here,
because I don't plan to make
any other choices
at all. d phi_i/dx.
It's a symmetric matrix now.
K_ji, because when I'm
choosing phis the same
as the V's, this is
what it looks like,
and if I switch j and i, I
don't see any difference.
So these are the things
that have to be integrated.
And those are the
ones we did integrate
when phi was piecewise linear.
When phi was piecewise
linear, the slope
was piecewise constant, and
we had really easy integrals.
Very easy integrals.
We had to pay
attention to where we
were was the slope on a minus
interval or on a plus interval,
but they were easy to compute.
And they led us back
to the kind of matrix
that we've seen before.
The twos and minus ones.
And our right hand
sides looked familiar.
Now, we've got new functions.
We still have the same formulas.
No change in formulas.
The system is really
quite successful,
because these are the things
that we have to compute.
So now I'll have to
integrate these parabolas,
these little parabolas,
half of the phis
will be little parabolas,
and their derivatives
will be linear.
So you see, I'll have
more calculations to do.
Which I don't plan to do,
but more integrations to--
For example, the
diagonal entry, say
2, 2, which will come from
that bubble with itself.
K_22, then, will be
the integral of c(x),
times the derivative
of that bubble, which
will be a straight line times
itself, so it would be squared.
And c is positive,
so this K_22 is
going to be some
nice positive number.
But we'll have to
figure out what it is.
Maybe I'll just say one fact
that we'll come back to.
That this K is symmetric
positive definite.
You thought it would be.
By using the letter K, we
kind of expected it to be.
And it will be.
It'll be symmetric because the
phis and the V's are the same.
And it turns out it's
positive definite.
So it's just great.
Just great.
We have a little more effort,
either to use a formula
for integrating polynomials,
or using numerical integration.
One way or another, and I
won't concentrate right now
on that point, we
get these numbers.
Okay.
Here's something
to concentrate on.
What kind of a
matrix K do we have?
Where will it be non-zero?
So it'll be eight
by eight, right?
I'll follow through
on that choice.
Just to say, where will
I see non-zeros here?
Because if you get
that point, you
see the way things
come together.
I'll just put a
little x for non-zero.
So K_11.
So what's that first row of K?
It's coming from the
first function, integrated
against itself.
K_11, if for 1, 1, we'll
get something there.
Will we have something
in the 1, 2 position?
That's my question, do we have
something in the 1, 2 position?
What's 1, 2?
That's this function against
the bubble function, yes?
Right?
They're non-zero
at the same place.
We can expect something there.
What about K_13?
That's what we've done
before, that's this one
against this one.
Yes?
We expect a non-zero there.
But then what?
After that, what will
the rest of that row be?
Zero.
Because that first
half hat doesn't
touch any of the others.
So let's go on.
Of course it'll be symmetric.
I know this much.
So this is the half hat row, and
this is the first bubble row.
Because the half hat
was phi_1 and now
the first bubble is phi_2.
What non-zeros do we get
in the stiffness matrix?
Again, we could unconstruct
it entry by entry.
Another way to construct it
will be element by element,
stamp them in.
You're beginning to
see the idea of that.
So what do I get
for that bubble?
I just look to see which
elements touch that bubble.
And which ones do?
One, two and three,
and not four.
Right?
In that row, we only get
-- so from that bubble,
I think we only get that much.
Now, we're not quite
seeing the picture yet.
Let me go to the next hat.
The hat, phi_2, and
then I'll do the bubble.
Oh, no, sorry, the
hat's numbered phi_3,
and then the next bubble
is numbered phi_4.
Where do I get zeros?
You can tell me,
where do I get zeros?
From inner products, from
these guys, when i is three.
So which phis does phi
number three overlap?
That's all I'm asking.
Does it overlap number one?
Yes.
Does it overlap phi number two?
You want to highlight,
so we're now
looking at phi_3, at this hat.
God, where's it gone?
That's the one we're doing now?
So what does it overlap?
It overlaps the half hat, does
it overlap the first bubble?
Yes.
Does it overlap itself?
Does it overlap
the second bubble?
Yes.
Does it overlap the next hat?
And then all zeros.
Okay, and now do one more row.
Bubble four.
So now I'm looking at this
guy, this next bubble. phi_4.
What does that overlap?
Does it overlap
the first half hat?
Nope.
Of course, symmetry
told us that.
Does the second bubble
overlap the first bubble?
No.
Big point: zero there.
Does the second bubble
overlap the hat?
Yes.
Does the second
bubble overlap itself?
Certainly, on the diagonal
we have something.
Does the second bubble
overlap the next hat, phi_5?
Yes.
And that's it.
I think.
The second level does not
overlap the following bubble.
I don't know if you see what
pattern we're getting here.
Those were special rows, because
that was only a half hat.
These are typical rows.
A typical hat function, that row
is showing us five non-zeros,
because it overlaps itself,
the neighboring hats,
and the neighboring bubbles.
But the bubble row
only has three,
because a bubble overlaps
itself, the neighboring
hat on each side, but not
the neighboring bubbles.
So we have only three non-zeros.
Do you see that the
next row will have five?
Will I get it right?
I hope so.
The next row we'll have,
I think they'd be here.
And then the next row will have
only three guys, maybe here,
here, here.
Well, it's certainly
a band matrix.
So you could say, okay,
it's a band matrix.
I wouldn't call it
tri-diagonal anymore.
If I showed you that matrix and
said, what kind of a matrix,
you'd say a band matrix.
If you wanted to tell me
that it had five bands,
you could maybe say
penta-diagonal, or something.
But it's easy to
work with, of course.
That's the point
of finite elements,
is that all the
functions are local,
so that we get all zeros when
trial functions don't overlap.
My additional point
was just a small one
that's not a big deal, but it's
a little bit worth noticing.
These rows with only three
entries, three non-zeros.
I guess what I want to say
is I have to solve eight
equations and eight unknowns.
And the normal way to do it
would be just elimination.
LU, that would work fine.
Start from the top,
eliminate, and you've got it.
And of course in one dimension,
nobody would do anything else.
That would be simple.
I just want to
say, these bubbles,
by giving me extra zeros, I
could eliminate the bubbles
first.
Can I just make this
point but not labor it?
I could eliminate
the bubbles first.
I could use this equation to
express the bubble coefficient
in terms of its neighbors.
I could use this one to
express the bubble coefficient
in terms of it neighbors.
And I could plug back
into the other equations.
I could simplify this.
I could get the bubbles
done first if I wanted.
I can see that to go
into the gory details
is probably not wise.
But bubbles are easy to do.
However there are
better elements.
So that's my discussion
of quadratic elements,
almost complete.
It's not a big favorite,
because cubics are better.
So why are cubics better?
Why are cubics better?
So you're going to say,
okay, upgrade to cubics.
How shall I do that?
And I want to say a word
about the error here.
Of course, the
reason quadratics are
better than cubics-- Sorry,
the reason why quadratics
are better than
linear, and cubics
will be better than quadratics
is I'm getting more accuracy.
Suppose my true solution
may be some curve like that.
Okay.
My piecewise linear
elements, suppose
the piecewise linear
elements happen to be,
as they would in a special model
problem, right on the money,
at the nodes.
Usually they won't be.
But what would be the
error in that one?
Well, no error at all at
the nodes as I've drawn it.
But that's not what
I'm interested in.
I'm interested in,
how big is that?
How far off is the displacement?
What's the maximum error
in the displacement?
Do you have any idea?
If this is size h.
Delta x, shall I call
it delta x, or h?
How far does a curving function
escape from the-- I need
to blow that up, don't I?
So I have a curving function
and a linear function,
and I want to know
how far apart they
are over a distance
of length delta x.
What's this scale?
That's the question.
It's just good, it'll
have a simple answer
and it's great to know it.
Anybody want to make a guess?
Is that scale of size delta x?
Is it of size delta x
squared, size delta x cubed?
It's that exponent of
delta x that is telling me
how big is the error?
And it's easy to find once
you get the hang of it.
Anybody want to make a guess?
Delta x?
Squared.
Squared would be
the right guess.
I could just turn that picture,
if we wanted, to-- Again, this
is delta x.
Now it would look like
that, pretty much.
Doesn't have to be
symmetric, of course,
because this could be
a complicated function.
But when I focus on a
little delta x interval,
every function looks
like a little polynomial.
The error there, let's see.
What would that function be?
I could go forever on this.
But look, if the
slope is something,
whatever, let me
change numbers here.
Let me call it from
zero to y, what
would be a little parabola
that has a slope of one,
let's say, at both ends.
What would that parabola be?
We probably have
seen that before.
If I wanted a slope
of one at both ends,
the polynomial
would be something
like-- What would it be?
Sorry, tell me that
little polynomial.
It's a polynomial in x,
it's just a quadratic.
Its slope is one, so it
maybe starts with an x.
I've got to bring it down here.
Is it x times one
minus x over-- I
didn't like y ever
in the first place.
What do I want to put there?
I don't want to put a one.
That would make it
look big. y is there.
Okay, I think that
quadratic is zero at zero,
because of that term.
It's zero at x=y,
It's second degree.
And I think its height
is a maximum right there.
And what is that height?
At y/2, this is
y/2, this is y/2.
That height is y
squared over four.
That's what I was shooting for.
The square.
That, in a little interval of
length y, for length delta x,
if I draw a little parabola
and I'm matching at the ends,
then the height it
reaches is like y squared.
That's the scale.
So my conclusion is that if I
use these basic hat function
elements, the error I get
is-- So can I list the errors?
The error is delta x squared.
That's the displacement error.
The error in u.
I'm not proving anything.
The careful discussion
of the accuracy
is a later section in the book.
But I'm trying to
make the main point,
is that if we're fitting
functions by straight lines,
then we have an error
of delta x squared.
And what's the slope error?
What do you think
is the slope error?
Because for us that
slope is important.
That's the error in the
stretching and the strain.
So the error in the
function is delta x squared.
The error in the slope will be
one order less, just delta x.
Okay, I'll come
back to all this.
Now, make a guess.
Suppose I include
these bubble functions.
With delta x as my length
scale horizontally,
what will be the
scale of the error?
What do you guess is the
expected error in displacement
for a general problem, for
a general c(x) and f(x).
Which I won't get exactly right,
but how close will I come?
I'll come within
delta x to what power?
Make a guess, please.
Four is an optimist.
I won't get up to four.
Cubed.
I'd only get cubed.
I'll get one by increasing
the degree of the polynomial
by one, I'll get
one degree better.
So you could look
at it this way.
Suppose I have any function.
This is a another way to
think about the accuracy.
Suppose I have
any function F(x).
The whole point of calculus
is that I could start,
if I start where it is at zero,
then I add in F'(0), the slope,
times x.
Then I add in 1/2 F''(0)
times x squared, and so on.
Right?
It's called the Taylor series.
And we're not paying any
attention to convergence,
or high order.
It's the early terms
that I'm interested in.
And the point is that
if my functions include
linear functions,
which the hats did,
they will be able to
get these terms right,
and this will be the
error that I missed.
I'm just looking to see what's
the first term in the Taylor
series that I will not get.
And if I only have
hat functions,
I can't get an x squared.
I can't get a parabola.
But when I go here and
include the x squareds,
I can get that term right.
So then it'll be the 1/6
f triple prime x cubed
that I miss.
So the error will be
the next missing term.
Okay, so that's thoughts
about the error.
And of course that's why those
elements are better than these.
They take more work,
but they are worth it.
But now I want to tell you
about the next elements.
Cubics.
Where you're going to expect
to get delta x to the fourth.
So now we're getting
serious accuracy.
Now we're getting good accuracy.
Of course our problem is not
the most difficult problem.
It's in 1-D. But this is good.
Okay.
This was now the fun in the
golden age of finite elements.
To construct cubics.
What shall I use as basis
functions for cubics?
So I want to have a
cubic in each piece.
First of all suppose I just
want no more than that.
Suppose I'm happy with
just continuous functions
and I let the slope jump.
What new trial function
shall I put in?
So I'm going to put in
new trial functions.
What will they look like?
Little cubics?
Little third degree pieces.
Instead of parabolas, they'll be
little pieces of third degree.
And I could put in
four more bubbles.
Four cubic bubbles.
So I would be up to
twelve degrees, twelve
by twelve matrices,
twelve functions.
And for that size delta x,
that would give me delta
x to the fourth.
So that would be okay.
There's a better idea.
You can see that I left space.
I'm going to make the
slope also continuous.
I'm not going to
allow jumps in slope.
Think, how will I do that?
So I'm going to call those
C-- what will I call that when
the slope is continuous?
The first derivative,
I'll call that C one,
continuous first derivative.
Okay.
Now I'm actually in
section 3.2, where
these better elements,
these really nifty elements
are constructed.
C^1, continuous slope, cubics.
Okay.
Ready for those?
What shall be my trial function
for continuous slope cubics?
So I have to start again.
I have to start again because
the hat functions are out now.
Those hat functions
have a jump in slope.
The bubble functions
I'm rethinking here to
create a better element.
Okay.
So let's just think, if
we've got a chance at it,
how could these elements work?
Okay, so here is the idea, then.
Here is my interval.
Zero to one, and here's
a typical interval.
And now at a typical
node, like node one,
I plan to have as unknowns
the height of the function, as
before, and also the slope.
So I want the function,
my trial function
is going to have some
height and some slope.
And at node two,
it's going to have
some height and some slope.
And here's the question.
Here's the good point.
That those four numbers, the
two heights and the two slopes,
that gives me four
things, four quantities.
How many quantities do I
need to determine a cubic?
So by a cubic, of course,
I mean by a cubic something
like a_0 plus a_1 x plus a_2
x squared and a_3 x cubed.
It's called a cubic
because it's x cubed.
So how many numbers here?
Four.
Perfect match.
There's exactly
one cubic that has
a specified height and a
specified slope at these two
ends.
There's one cubic
that'll do that.
And then whatever
the height here is
and whatever the slope
there is, there'll
be one cubic with that
height and that slope
that comes into this one.
And you see that they will
have continuous slope.
Because of course the slope
is continuous in between;
it's a polynomial.
The question is
always at the nodes.
But I use the same number
coming from the left
and from the right.
The slope has become
an extra unknown.
So I have height,
slope at every point.
So that's one way to describe
these trial functions now.
The trial functions have height
and also slope at each node.
So what does that mean?
That means that I'm going
to have two unknowns.
Two functions, two
trial functions,
each with its own
coefficient at each node.
So if I take a typical node
there, I want two functions.
Okay, this is interesting.
But you see what I'm creating.
I think I'm going to
get two functions there,
two functions there,
two functions there, right?
Because nobody's
constraining that.
So I'm up to eight.
And how many
functions do you think
I'm going to have
associated with that node?
Only one.
Why?
Because the height is fixed.
So I think I've got nine
trial functions here.
And if we can see
what those are,
then the system will take over.
They're my phi_1
to phi_9, whatever,
they plug in here, they
plug in the right-hand side,
I'll have a nine by
nine stiffness matrix.
It'll be local again.
Well, let's see if we can
figure out these functions.
Okay, so you have the idea?
I'm expecting two
trial functions.
One is sort of a round hat.
All right, let me draw that.
The round hat function
will be the function--
These will be the round hats,
and they'll be associated with,
they give me heights.
And then I'll also
have an additional one,
except at the last node.
And these will be-- I don't
know what to call them yet.
You'll have to give me a name.
These will give me the slopes.
Okay.
So what does a
round hat look like?
Now these have to
be, follow my rules,
they have to be
continuous, their slope
has to be continuous.
And I want to take the one
that has height one and zero
slope there.
And it should have height
zero and zero slope, here.
Height zero, zero slope.
You see what it's going to be?
This phi, whatever
number it is, it'll
be the phi whose
coefficient tells me
the height at node one.
So here's node one.
What will it look like?
What will this function do?
Well, there is
exactly one cubic that
starts from zero with
slope zero and ends there,
ends at one with slope zero.
Right?
That's what we said; four
numbers determine that cubic
in that interval.
Then there's another cubic that,
with those two numbers again,
that keeps the continuous
slope, and these two numbers
in this interval.
And of course it'll
just be symmetric.
You see the round hat?
So that's the basis
function, the trial
function that has continuous
slopes and heights, of course,
and it has height
one at that point.
And now let me draw the one that
has height zero, slope zero;
height zero, slope zero.
And what do I want
it to do there?
What should this
function be like?
It should be the one that
tells-- Its coefficient will
tell me the slope.
So I want it to have a slope
of one and a height of zero.
Do you see these
functions, shall
I call these, the height
functions, phi h 1?
That's the phi, that's the
trial function that tells me
the height at node one.
When I take
combinations, it gets
multiplied by U h 1, which is
exactly the height at node one.
Now what about this guy?
This guy is going to start
with zero slope at zero.
It's going to be a cubic,
and there's exactly
one cubic that'll do it.
It'll look a little like this.
Then there'll be
exactly one cubic
that does that and
gets back to zero.
You see that that's possible?
In each interval,
I've got four numbers:
two heights, two slopes.
So this would be a picture
of the phi slope at node one
function.
So that's a standard function,
it's a cubic, piecewise cubic.
Local again, because in all
these intervals it's zero.
And it will be, when I
go to take combinations
of all these guys,
it'll be multiplied
by its coefficient, U slope one.
And then I'll have
nine altogether.
But those two are
the typical ones.
Do you do see how that's going?
It's more subtle
than hat functions.
Suppose whoever's writing
the finite element code
gets a formula for those
phis and plugs them
into the integrals, comes
out with a stiffness matrix.
Actually, we could even look
at that stiffness matrix.
This is a good way to
understand the picture.
Now it'll be nine by nine.
Right?
So here we'll have a typical,
this'll be our phi height 1
row, and this'll be
our phi slope 1 row,
and this'll be our phi
height 2 row, and so on.
Of course, I didn't
leave room for all--
What will a typical row of this
stiffness matrix have in it?
I'm just asking about the
overlaps. phi_1 height
certainly overlaps itself.
Does phi_1 height
overlap phi_1 slope?
Yes or no?
Sure.
Does phi_1 height
overlap phi_2 height?
Yes.
Because the phi_2 height
will go up like that.
You see?
And the phi_2 slope.
So actually we'll have,
I think we'll have
six non-zeros on a typical row.
Is that right?
Six non-zeros?
Because a typical h-- this
is maybe not so typical,
because to the left of
it there's only one,
there's no-- No, there are two.
Right?
There's a phi_0, phi
h 0 and a phi s 0.
Sure, there are two
here, the two guys
here, there's one
height guy, and there's
one-- what's cooking in that?
Oh, it's got a slope of one
and it gets back to zero.
What I'm drawing now
in little dashed lines
was the phi slope 0.
The one that gives
me a slope at node
zero, and this is the one
that gives me a height.
Yes.
Do you see it?
So above this was a phi
slope 0, and stuck in there
was a phi height 0.
Six-diagonal matrix.
I think it helps to draw
that little thing with x's
and zeros, because then you sort
of see how things are fitting
together.
Okay.
So these functions now, I've
gone into section 3.2 for that.
I want to go to a
slightly different topic,
and then I'll come back in
section 3.2 to these cubics.
So these are C^1 cubics,
continuous slope cubics.
Very interesting construction.
Are you seeing how it could
go in more dimensions?
I mean, that's what we'll
see for Laplace's equation,
how can you construct
quadratics, cubics in a plane.
It gets interesting.
But you'll get the
knack of these guys.
These are pretty
direct, and very useful.
So what's the effect?
The effect is that
we get a matrix.
It looks quite like
a difference matrix.
Well, actually, the height
rows and-- the numbers
in the height rows and the
slope rows look different.
We're getting
something new here.
We're getting a matrix, a KU=F,
that's going to give us fourth
order accuracy.
So the accuracy has moved up.
So we've got up to
fourth order accuracy,
which we could get
by finite differences
by a lot of patience.
We get them from finite
elements in a straight way.
Okay, any question
or discussion?
I'm talking real fast to get
this new idea of constructing
finite elements here.
I do want to say
something about that line.
Because that's a
part of this business
of estimating the accuracy.
It's a key idea in the
background of the Galerkin
method.
And the minimum form would
be associated with names
like Rayleigh and Ritz.
All right.
I'll just go directly
to that, if I may.
So what I want to do is tell
you, for our model problem,
I want to tell you the strong
form-- Let me do it this way.
I'll put the strong
form, the weak form,
and then I want to add
in the minimum form.
Okay.
So the strong form of
our equation was minus
the derivative of
c*du/dx equal f.
Okay.
What was the weak form?
This is an f(x).
The weak form, how do
you get to the weak form?
You multiply both sides by a
test function, you integrate,
you integrate by parts, and you
get this beautifully symmetric
form that we have up
there, du/dx*dv/dx*dx,
equals the integral
of f(x)*v(x)*dx.
I write that again, just so
you see the nice symmetry
of that weak form.
And it's for all test
functions v. Okay.
I'm shooting for a
third description.
A third description
of the same problem.
And it's really neat to
see that you have that.
Let me just see it first
in the discrete case.
The discrete case, the strong
form would be A transpose C
Au=f.
That's the strong form.
Right?
I always like to see
the discrete one first,
and then the continuous.
Okay, what would be the weak
form in the discrete case?
I would multiply by
a vector v, and I
would take inner products, A
transpose C Au inner product
with v, equals f inner product
with v. You can use dot,
or-- So that would
be the weak form.
I've just taken the dot
product of both sides
with v. Now you'll see the weak
form better if, what should I
do?
What would make that look nice?
So that's the dot product
of A transpose C Au with v.
And what do I do to
make that look nice?
Do you get the idea yet?
It doesn't look pretty to me.
It's all lopsided.
Right?
So what can I do
with A transpose?
What's the rule
about A transpose?
That if I have A
transpose times something,
dotted with something,
what can I do?
I can move the A transpose
over to the other guy.
And what will it
be when I do that?
So I take it away from here,
and what do I put there?
A. That's the whole
point of transposes.
Transposes, you put them on the
other side of the dot product,
you take the transpose, so
it would be literally, maybe
A transpose
transpose, which is A.
What I just did there
is integration by parts.
Well, summation by
parts, because I'm
in the discrete case.
The whole idea of
integration by parts
amounted to taking A transpose
off of u, off of this,
and putting A over there.
Isn't that neat?
And you see that this CAu,
Av is just what I have here.
C, A is derivative,
so this is CAu, Av.
Inner product.
That's cool.
That's just like
how it should be.
I just followed that rule,
that A transpose times
something, shall I call it
w, inner product with u,
is the same as (w, Au).
That if I bring
A transpose over,
it becomes an A. If
I bring an A over,
it would become an A transpose.
All right, what about
the minimum form?
Have I got one minute
to do the minimum form?
Yes.
So what's the minimization
that's hiding behind this?
The minimization in the
discrete case, do you remember?
We're looking at Ku=f.
And some quadratic quantity from
least squares has its minimum
when Ku=f.
And it's 1/2 u transpose
Ku minus u transpose f.
Where K is A transpose C A.
This is the minimum statement
of the problem.
That if I look for the u that
minimizes that quadratic,
it leads me to
the equation Ku=f.
So that's the minimum statement.
And if we want it to really
look perfectly like the others,
I would put in A
transpose C A. Okay.
Can I write down next time,
because our time is really up.
It's not fair to-- Al I'm
going to do is write down
the same thing here.
I'm minimizing 1/2-- Oh,
I'm going to do it anyway.
c(x) du/dx squared, minus
the integral of f(x)u(x).
So that's the minimum problem.
Minimize over all
u, this quadratic.
This is the right way
to see these problems.
You see a differential
equation, which
we use for finite
differences; you
see a weak form, which we
use for finite elements;
and now you see a minimum form.
Okay, that gives you
something to think about.
And there'll be a homework
on finite elements
that'll give you a
chance to use them.
Okay, thank you.